[Music]
hi everybody welcome to the Animal Park
at the conservators Center we're gonna
take you on a little behind-the-scenes
tour just to take a look at how we are
functioning during the Cova 19 and emic
so without being able to have our public
tours here
the animals are definitely getting a
little bit less attention than they're
used to thankfully our staff is
committed to their behavior and their
health so what we're doing to protect
the animals is wearing masks and
covering our hands and gloves the masks
that I am wearing right now it was
actually made out of autoclave material
and donated by one of our local
veterinarians so thankfully as we are in
all weather facility the keepers have
had to wear face masks around the animal
just to be able to protect ourselves
from the cold or any kind of nasty wind
so the animals have been pretty well
desensitized I wouldn't say that they
are totally used to it and they don't
love it they do use a lot of facial cues
to be able to kind of communicate with
us thankfully within our team we're
really well trained and we know to kind
of be ready for that and the bigger
thing for us to be able to show them is
more our eyes and our attitude and we
just make sure to take our time and
either use it as a training tool or
change our husbandry so that the animal
stays as comfortable as possible being
behavior specialists we are able to
actually share space with our wolf pups
they just turned two-year-old about a
week maybe two weeks ago and we've been
with them since they were about eight
weeks old so the bubblebath that we're
providing them with kind of provides a
lot of different stimulus our
northwestern wolves are very interested
in water in general so anytime that we
can make that water a little bit more
exciting is gonna give them something
else to think about within their
environment by adding something as
simple as bubbles now they can't really
see the bottom of the pool it adds
another texture another smell and just a
general complexity to their environment
something that they don't engage with
every single day makes it so that it's a
little bit more interesting when we do
provide it for them one of our large
concerns here of course is how long this
quarantine is going to last making sure
that we keep track of things like our
supply chain of the animal health
keeping our veterinarians up to date on
everything that's going
we've been kind of limiting how many
resources we are using at a time to
ensure that we can use them for as long
as possible
thankfully as a small nonprofit we are
still able to keep all of our paid staff
employed right now but everybody is
doing things that are a little bit
outside of their normal task regiment
they're helping out in construction more
they're helping on an animal care when
they can more of our social animals may
get a little bit more needy if they are
just used to seeing the same people over
and over again so changing how we engage
with the animals may be taking our lunch
break with them taking a book out to
read the longer that this goes on it's
basically just the more creative that
we're gonna have to become so as you can
see we provide the animals the choice
and control to be a part of their
therapy so I have the light on Lena for
just a quick moment to see how she felt
she left the area and I didn't follow
after her versus us so if you do
anything that's on the ground he just
wants to be a part of your life you
can't even really notice that there's a
life or any kind of therapy or anything
happening on his back end now he wants
to say I know you pour pee on me I wanna
thank you all for joining us today and
our little behind-the-scenes tour we
cannot wait to have visitors be able to
come back on grounds and join us for a
real tour here with us and with the
animals in the meantime if you have
anything to spare we are so grateful for
any kind of donation you can find a lot
of our options on our website animal
park and Sea Org you can also follow us
on social media we have Facebook Twitter
Instagram and even some really cute
videos on tik-tok if you have time to
reach out to any of your local
institutions as well we are all in this
together